I remember meeting Royce Gracie in uh
Harbor City I heard of that guy he's a
pretty interesting character I remember
seeing him in a bootleg VHS video and I
told him about it uh we were doing a
class uh out at a
uh Emerson knives it's a it's a it's a
Knife Company but the but Mr Emerson
also has like a Jiu Jitsu gym there
where Royce trades out of that's his uh
that's his space
and you know they're teaching how to
defend against somebody trying to stab
you and I'm showing them all the ways
you can get around that and fabricate
and improvise and smuggle things
basically the the adversarial side of
that it's just that's what I'm known for
the psychology and kind of the ways that
people do that and
I remember him seeing some of the stuff
that I was doing and just being like
where are you from Mexico
makes sense you know somebody from
Brazil you know tipping the hat to
somebody from Mexico as far as
it was him uh seeing the violence and
some of the uh the mentality behind it
so for people who don't know who is
Gracie is the legendary martial artist
that probably introduced Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu to the American Audio to the world
through the process of UFC and showing
the effectiveness of it and um
in practice that a little skinny guy can
defeat a big aggressive guy so an
anaconda that's a small Anaconda walking
into that uh ring with his family behind
wearing pajamas wearing pajamas and they
were like what is this guy wearing
pajamas for and then he would strangle
people with those pajamas uh I remember
seeing that and just having it I think
probably what a generation before had
with Bruce Lee I guess or my generation
was Royce walking into that uh
walking into that octagon and changing
you know paradigms
seeing him in that gym
it's also I have a gun owner and shooter
which is interesting you know having
seeing somebody like him who is
you know well versed with his hands also
be a man that has gone into the realm of
being well versed with with weaponry
which is an aspect of of martial arts
and uh the Marshall way of thinking that
you know some people kind of
the PRS will stick with one aside of it
but he's obviously a warrior in a lot of
ways so just a small tangent so you're
somebody that
you don't just look at unarmed combat
you look at the full spectrum of the the
chaos of combat that's outside of the
realm of Jiu Jitsu and even just mixed
martial arts unarmed armed with knives
and Beyond yes was his mind open to the
the Fuller spectrum of violence yeah I
mean he was he was in the middle of this
class that we were doing where people
were basically focusing on both
Ernest Emerson who's a famous for his
knives he's that's a nice company he's
done knives for NASA you know not only
that but he's also a very Avid martial
artist he trained with a lot of Filipino
martial arts related to knives and stuff
like that but a different mindset you
know a defensive mindset ton of trained
people how to defend against that and
you have Royce who's uh he's from Brazil
I mean he has some Street in him that's
something that you know those guys
we say in Mexico
uh seeing the ways he would uh he
stepped in there and and provided some
encouragement to the people there as far
as uh you know how people sometimes
focus on the uh
this is a system and this is a way but
there's other ways out there that might
negate or defeat the ways that you are
concentrating on you know
so kind of get out of that bubble